[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm filming a documentary called the
presenter relax we tested both plural
titles are out this year it's not the
artists anyway this could be flowing
honey okay weird Gabriel o space yeah
our da our category tonight is best
documentary please don't talk when I'm
talking it'll make post a nightmare this
thing wants to be on Netflix by midnight
documentaries has the great Mark Twain
said truth is stranger than boring sorry
feels scripted it's weird
sign what get this get this what you're
doing right now
seriously this is disrespectful and it's
disruptive right yes and it's totally
crazy yeah look I turn down the
descendants to prep for this so I don't
want to know when you hear about that
you're insane
know what I'm doing is bleeding edge
this is live documentary that's called
the news no yes don't talk what I'm
talking okay and there is no way you
turned down the descendants am i right
am i right here literal title by the way
here are the nominees for Best
Documentary Feature
Helen back again danfung dennis and Mike
Lohner if a tree falls a story of the
Earth Liberation Front Marshall curry
and Sam Coleman Paradise Lost 3
purgatory Joe Burrell injure and Bruce
Sinofsky pinna vim benders and John
Carroll ringer undefeated tjmartin Dan
Lindsay and rich middle miss and the
Oscar goes to
undefeated tjmartin Dan Lindsay and rich
middle
dan Lindsey says he will never forget
the audience response to their first
screening making the first two years
they invested worth it this is the first
Academy Award nomination for tjmartin
Dan Lindsey and rich middle man this is
ridiculous
Wow okay we want to we want to thank the
Academy for this honor a year ago today
we were sitting in our editing room
depressed think you know what he was
ever gonna see this movie and a friend
said don't worry next year you will be
at the Oscars and we said you're an
idiot
so we'd like to take this opportunity to
apologize to him and say you're a lot
smarter than we thought
we want to share this award with our
fellow producers at cunningham glenn
zipper and seth gordon if they didn't
believe in us we would not be standing
here today thank you so much
I'd also like to acknowledge our fellow
nominees they have inspired us in so
many ways it's it's they should be up
here with us actually that'd be [ __ ]
wonderful sign language but you know we
also are extremely indebted to our
friends and family without them and
their support over the years there's no
way that we'd be able to do this Harvey
Weinstein the weinstein company nigel
sinclair spitfire ralph zipper and
Zipporah Brothers films Chris Miller
[Music]
[Applause]